merci pour votre invitation et c'est un
plaisir d'être aujourd'hui dans votre
région
en souhaitant comme nous tous ici le
meilleur succès à xavier bertrand à son
équipe espérait et faire en sorte que
décembre 2015 soit le mois de
l'alternance et de l'espoir dans votre
région
au boulot bon courage le plaisir et
l'honneur et c'est pour cela que nous
sommes ici de partager une réunion de
famille et il est heureux aujourd'hui
que ce soit avec nous qui a été avec
nous au moment du déjeuner alain juppé
est tout à l'heure nicolas sarkozy
le plus le mieux et le plus nous sommes
militants jeunes ou moins jeunes
responsables modestes ou plus illustres
à partager ces moments de la vie
familiale de notre formation politique
est bien le plus nous sommes nombreux
le mieux c'est cet esprit de
rassemblement cet esprit d'unité tout
simplement l'identité de notre famille
il est important que nous affirmions ce
rassemblement ce campus des jeunes
républicains aujourd'hui c'est un moment
de la vie de notre famille
il est donc important diète vous y est
nous y sommes c'est bien
campus des jeunes républicains
c'est alors un moment d' enthousiasme
c'est un moment d'engagement c'est aussi
un moment idéal
notre parti c'est d'abord le parti de la
liberté est aujourd'hui puis dans tout
ce que nous allons réfléchir proposer
d'ici le printemps 2017 puis ensuite
accomplir et réussir oui nous voulons
que 2017 soit pour notre parti pour
notre pays
le printemps des libertés une évidence
diraient certains
non ça n'est pas une évidence
hélas le matraquage fiscal pratiqué avec
autant de continuité en réalité
aujourd'hui françois hollande ergote sur
le thème est ce que je baisse les impôts
mais ce que j'augmente les taxes
subtilité présidentielle mais pas
vraiment dans le portefeuille des
français
la réalité est que la liberté de votre
pouvoir d'achat la liberté de vos choix
en tant que famille en tant
qu'entreprise cette liberté depuis 2012
a été considérablement entamé à 10 mai
alors nous disons non aux partis de la
fiscalité qui essayent de s'acheter une
vertu vers la fin de son mandat mais
nous ne sommes pas dupes
quand on reçoit beaucoup de coups sur la
tête en avoir un peu moins d'un coup ça
ne devient pas une caresse les quelques
gâteries fiscale de fin de mandat
l'achat de clientèle opéré par françois
hollande son gouvernement et son parti
n'en lève rien à ce que sera au final le
bilan de ce mandat
une ardoise fiscale particulièrement
lourde
une entrave à la liberté des français ça
vaut pour le ps et pour la gauche mais
regardez les amis je vous encourage à
lire attentivement le programme du front
national vous avez une accumulation de
mesures interventionnistes
nationalisation des banques contrôle des
prix vous avez paragraphe après
paragraphe
en réalité la négation du monde
d'aujourd'hui tel qu'il est la négation
de la liberté la négation de vous même
dans les choix que vous faites dans la
liberté que vous voulez avoir en tant
que consommateur en tant que salarié en
tant que chef d'entreprise
alors oui oui nous devons être le parti
de la liberté est ce que l'on peut
assumer le mot est ce que la liberté est
ce qu'être libéral au fond ça ne fait
pas peur on l'entend parfois
eh bien je dis que non si on veut demain
que la france s'en sorte
si on veut demain que la france ne soit
pas sur le côté de l'histoire
si on veut continuer de voir la france
en grand si on veut continuer de compter
dans le monde de demain
la liberté et la clé mêmes même regarder
la crise de l'agriculture
ces dernières semaines certains ont dit
à gauche à l'extrême droite et on laisse
dire oh la la c'est la faute du
libéralisme mais les amis des charges
sociales excessive des réglementations
tatillonnes des normes trop sévère
qu'est ce que ça a dit libéral ça alors
s'il s'agit en effet de libérer
l'économie de faire en sorte que
l'agriculture puisse davantage investir
demain de faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs français saisissent tout
leur talent tout leur potentiel pour
conter véritablement dans le monde de
demain et la france le peux et nos
agriculteurs le peuvent
ce n'est pas de moins de liberté dont
nous avons besoin ce n'est pas de plus
de charges n'est pas de plus de
contraintes mais c'est véritablement oui
d'une ouverture d'un sursaut il s'agit
pas d'être naïf mais ce n'est pas
d'enfermer la france comme le veut le
front national et comme d'une certaine
manière y conduit la gauche dans le
déclin qu'elle mène ce n'est pas en
enfermant la france que nous gagnerons
nuit en agriculture ni en industrie ni
dans le touriste ni nulle part
ce n'est pas par naïveté je voulais
orde mais c'est en musclant notre pays
en faisant en sorte que la liberté de
chacun et que l'action déterminée des
pouvoirs publics permettent pas
simplement de dire notre pays a du
talent ça c'est vrai une fois qu'on l'a
dit permettent de faire en sorte que ce
talent soit véritablement mobilisé que
nous ne soyons pas les spectateurs
passifs du déclin de la france mais que
nous soyons acteurs du sursaut tant
qu'il n'est pas trop tard
il est important il est important
aujourd'hui et demain pour les élections
régionales et pour nous tous les
scrutins qui viendront d'ouvrir les yeux
de nos concitoyens sur le bilan
désastreux de la gauche au pouvoir
ils savent le faire par eux mêmes mais
il n'est jamais inutile de faire de la
pédagogie on entend vous le savez de
temps en temps dans certains milieux
dans les campagnes électorales aussi oh
là là vous savez ils disent à leur
programme mais sans doute il ne le
ferons pas parce qu'ils sont pas si bête
que ça
je le dis souvent ne venait jamais pour
quelqu'un au seul motif qu'il ne
tiendrait pas ses engagements parce que
quand il ya des âneries et j'oserais
même dire des conneries dans le
programme de françois hollande
hélas ce soit par volonté soit par
contrainte
je m'en fiche ce qui compte c'est le
résultat il est capable et il est même
contraint de le faire vous avez vu le
cafouillage cette semaine sur fessenheim
la réalité est que les verts encore
aujourd'hui tiennent le gouvernement et
risque de contraindre à faire une ânerie
majeur sur le plan de la politique
énergétique
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social sur le plan fiscal
ça coûterait des milliards d'euros il y
a aussi une urgence bien sûr c'est de
dire ce que nous sommes
la critique est indispensable mais elle
ne suffit pas la gauche c'est un
désastre
espérez vous imaginez qu'on va gagner
simplement comme ça vous le savez parce
que vous êtes lucide ça ne serait pas
raisonnable
rien n'est acquis d'avancé le résultat
ni des régionales en décembre je
souhaite le meilleur à xavier et à tous
nos amis ni des élections
présidentielles ensuite des législatives
en 2017
mais tu écris à kid avance nous devons
porter un projet nous devons dire ce que
nous sommes
eh oui chers amis vous l'avez dit déjà
nous devons proclamer et porter nos
valeurs
mais il ne suffit pas de dire que nous
avons des valeurs il faut dire lesquels
avec exigence avec cohérence avec
constance honorer les combats que nous
avons menés tout au long de cette
législature
le respect de la personne le respect de
la famille
nous sommes pour la liberté nous sommes
pour le respect de la personne parce que
nous croyons fondamentalement à
l'autonomie de chacune et chacun d'entre
vous davantage qu'à la toute puissance
de l'état
une personne qui n'est pas isolé une
personne qui n'est pas égoïste
une personne qui n'est pas
individualiste qui mesure sa
responsabilité
la liberté ce n'est pas un caprice c'est
d'abord la responsabilité pour les
autres c'est l'abbé pierre qui le
disaient et les autres l'autonomie des
personnes
c'est bien sûr naturellement le lien
qu'elle forme dans la famille je
discutais avec l'un d'entre nous tout à
l'heure en or faisant la queue pour le
déjeuner et cet ami me disait mais au
fond quand on parle d'éducation
probablement nous ne parlons pas
suffisamment de la famille cette famille
méprisés par le gouvernement aujourd'hui
y compris dans le domaine de l'éducation
méprisé par madame vallaud belkacem
j'ai eu la mauvaise idée
enfin moi je la trouve plutôt juste deux
qualifiés madame vallaud-belkacem de
khmers roses souriante
madame vallaud belkacem a considéré que
mère rose c'était raciste non c'est une
expression politique et souriante elle a
trouvé que c'était sexiste
avec tout le respect que je dois aux
femmes considéré que dire d'une personne
qu'elle est souriante serait
nécessairement appliqué à une femme et
sexiste et le pire des stéréotypes de
genre auquel on puisse penser
ne nous laissons pas trompés par les
débats actuels sur l'éducation
ce que nous voulons ce n'est pas moins
de responsabilités c'est plus de
responsabilités en particulier pour les
chefs d'établissement ce que nous
voulons ce n'est pas moins d'autonomie
mais plus d'autonomie pour les
établissements car la réalité c'est que
des réformes pro modeste de l'éducation
comme dans d'autres domaines ne
suffiront pas si on veut véritablement
redonner de l'espoir et l'optimisme
notre pays
il y à un débat d'ailleurs aussi au sein
de notre famille politique
sur d'autres sujets prenez l'exemple du
code du travail
il ya deux écoles et le débat est
respectable
ceux qui considèrent qu'il faut
identifier quelques points qui posent le
plus problème et il faudrait les
corriger
ce dont je suis qui considère qu' on est
arrivé à un tel degré de contrainte
d'absurdité de lourdeur et de poids sur
l'économie et l'emploi dans notre pays
qu'il faut en réalité prendre un petit
paquet de pages blanches pas trop
nombreuses et écrire véritablement à
partir de ces pages blanches
le danger pour notre famille politique
ça n'est pas d'être trop audacieux
demain c'est au contraire de ne pas
l'être assez je vous disais la famille
je reviens là dessus il fera que nous
ayons de la suite dans les idées nos
amis pour reconstruire une politique
familiale
moi je ne suis pas résigné à la loi
taubira je le dis comme je le pense et
je l'assumé on ne peut pas avoir mené
les combats que nous avons menés pendant
des mois
être sur l'engagement qui en a qui en
réalité aura le plus marqué cette
législature est considéré que ce que la
gauche fait est qu'on sait apprécier
comme une brique de la nation et que
rien ne pourrait bouger de ce que nous
avons tant critiqué
que vaut une opposition et que voudrait
une opposition demain qui critique quand
elle est dans l'opposition et qui
avalerait quand lé majorité
et puis aussi sur un terrain plus
matérielles mais cela compte
françois hollande donne des leçons de
fiscalité il va acheter une clientèle
mais demandez à ceux qui ont subi la
baisse du quotient familial à ceux qui
ont subi le plafonnement des allocations
familiales à ceux qui ont subi parmi les
retraités
la fiscalisation des droits familiaux de
retraite et bien il y a ces pans
essentiels de notre politique familiale
que nous devrons aussi rétablir les
choses sont aussi simple que cela
quand une loi est mauvaise quand une
disposition est mauvaise il faut être
capable de la changer
ça ne doit pas résumer notre projet
politique on doit être capable d'aller
de l'avant on doit être capable
d'innover de proposer des choses
nouvelles vigoureuse intelligente adapté
au monde de demain
mais n'ayons pas trop de pudeur là
dessus la gauche les amis quand elle a
envie de modifier quelque chose que nous
avons fait avant elle se gênent pas
beaucoup alors ça veut dire quoi faire
de la politique
et à voir le complexe qu'il faudrait
surtout pas toucher un cheveu à ce que
les socialistes ont fait pas vous pas
moi pas ça
le respect de la personne c'est aussi le
respect de notre parole à l'égard des
migrants
je propose une politique simple oui
l'asile fait partie des valeurs et de la
définition la république
mais la ville ce n'est pas une créance
l'asile ce n'est pas un droit
automatique
ce n'est pas je demande l'asile est
gelée l'asile c'est un devoir
c'est un devoir que doit exercer la
nation la république et ceux de voir on
doit l'exercer dans de bonnes conditions
on doit donc l'exercer en fonction de
nos moyens en fonction des situations et
en fonction des publics qui demandent
l'asile
il n'y a pas de droit absolu et
systématique à l'asile il y a un devoir
ce devoir fait partie de notre
responsabilité
il fait partie de notre identité il fait
partie de notre idéal politique mais il
faut trouver
c'est subtil jeu vous la corde mais
c'est là que se trouve le bon réglage de
l'action publique
c'est là que se trouve la vérité c'est
là que se trouve l'efficacité entre ce
qu'est notre devoir mais ce qui n'est
pas un droit
en face le devoir c'est la république le
droit ça serait un automatisme
ça serait une créance et je ne suis pas
dans la république des créances je ne
suis pas dans la république des
automatismes alors enfin je veux chers
amis vous entraîner sur un chemin qui
est celui de la responsabilité et de la
vérité la vérité c'est le désastre
socialistes d'aujourd'hui
la vérité c'est aussi l'échec de 2012
tels que les français l'ont dit au
moment des élections
malheureusement injustement mais le
peuple est souverain et donc nous devons
mais toute notre énergie à proposer à
nos concitoyens des chemins innovant le
monde d'aujourd'hui l'économie
d'aujourd'hui la société d'aujourd'hui
des propositions efficaces opérationnel
la qualité de notre projet la qualité de
notre proposition politique n'est pas
tant dans la force des formules n'est
pas tant dans l'élan du discours mais
elle est dans le jugement que chaque
français prononce
je viens d'entendre quelque chose est ce
que raisonnablement ils le feront est-ce
que c'est vraisemblable est ce que ça
sera efficace les propos les plus mal
les propos les plus violents ne sont pas
nécessairement les propos les plus
crédibles
soyons attentifs à ce que nous proposons
s'agissant de la syrie
faut-il intervenir ou non quels types
d'interventions la politique menée par
le gouvernement n'est pas heureuse
soyons attentifs à ne pas dire n'importe
quoi fota est immédiatement démentie par
les événements ou tout simplement par le
bon sens de ce nos concitoyens qu'ils
savent que les choses parfois sont
compliquées lisez les papiers de notre
excellent collègue arnaud danjean qui a
très bien souligné combien il s'agit pas
de faire des moulinets et des grandes
déclarations mais de proposer aux
français ce qui est vraisemblable
réaliste et efficace dans le domaine de
la sécurité il est essentiel de lutter
contre le terrorisme et bien sûr sur le
territoire national mais n'y a pas de
baguette magique
il faut évidemment une continuité il
faut des efforts il faut des moyens
vous êtes comme moi indigné de constater
que des terroristes soupçonnés
potentiellement identifiés n'ont pas été
suivies et surveiller avec suffisamment
de continuité de sorte qu'au final ils
arrivent à commettre des attentats
mortels ou en tout cas serait est en
situation de le faire une fois qu'on a
dit ça il faut identifier les points
d'une action raisonnable et efficace
quand certains disent qu'il suffirait
d'expulser toutes les personnes suivies
d'une fiche est ce si on est un tant
soit peu attachés à l'état de droit
eh bien on sait très bien qu'une fiche
de police ne crée pas du droit et ne
suffit pas pour expulser quelqu'un si
vous donnez à cette fiche en effet
juridique vous mettez les magistrats
dans le système et ya plus de police
si vous donnez à toute mesure de police
cet effet il n'y a plus de police
or nous voulons des propositions
efficaces je vous le dis l'efficace et
l'opposition ça n'est pas le concours
lépine des propositions les plus
violentes et les plus échevelés soyons
attentifs à la solidité de ce que nous
proposons la carence l'indignité de la
gauche ne justifie pas de notre part une
surenchère qui ne serait pas
opérationnel et efficace
les français ne se paye pas de mots les
français ne nous élirons pas pour notre
bonne pomme et jeunes républicains sont
sympathiques
nous avons tous une bonne pomme qui
sûrement donne envie de voter mais les
français répondent à une première
exigence est celle de l'utilité
ils nous demandent pas si on est beau et
nous demandent à quoi on sert n'a pensé
à mes à quelque chose il faut des
propositions crédibles et c'est le point
de départ de l'alternance voilà quelques
idées que je voulais partager avec vous
parce que si nous sommes rassemblés ce
soir c'est que nous y croyons
c'est qu'en politique on a envie de
mettre de l'enthousiasmé qu'on a envie
bien sûr d'y mettre de la jeunesse qu'on
a envie d'y mettre de la fougue qu'on a
envie d'y mettre de la nouveauté mais
nous qui consacre du temps militant de
base parlementaire ancien ministe sûrs
président tout ce que vous voulez eh
bien nous devons d'abord comprendre que
c'est une affaire sérieuse dont il
s'agit si les français se mettent à tant
de distance de la politique c'est pas
pour des affaires de cumul des mandats
ou de je ne sais quoi c'est
fondamentalement parce que les résultats
ne sont pas à la hauteur et parce que
parfois ils ont le sentiment que pour
trop d'hommes ou de femmes politiques
la politique serait un jeu la politique
serait une forme de cynisme la politique
serait une estrade davantage que des
convictions
si nous sommes ici c'est que nous sommes
convaincus que la politique vaut mieux
c'est que nous sommes convaincus que
votre région peut basculer
c'est que nous sommes convaincus que les
jeunes républicains porte cet espoir et
cette exigence c'est que nous aimons
notre famille des républicains et que
nous aimons la france